campaign correspondent Robert Costa and
CBS News legal analyst Ricky Clement
good morning to both of you Bob I want
to start with you we don't know exactly
what's in this indictment the special
counsel is not talking and it is under
seal but you're talking to law
enforcement sources about the
seriousness of this case what are you
learning
Tony good morning speaking last night
and this morning to former Federal
prosecutors who know Jack Smith the
special counsel they say he would not
bring these series of charges unless he
felt that he could win this case that
this is something that is serious
engraved when it deals with National
Security matters it's not only about
alleged obstruction of a federal
investigation in the attempt to secure
these documents it's also about having
these materials and potentially having
Criminal Intent to try to take them from
the White House to his Florida home
Ricky what do you make of the decision
to bring the case in Florida as opposed
to bringing it in D.C which they could
have done
I think it was a very smart strategic
move on the part of the special
prosecutor it takes away one line of
defense and a motion to dismiss from the
defense because the defense was easily
able to say everything happened at
Mar-A-Lago everything so the venue
should be in Southern Florida and if you
made Mr prosecutor the venue in
Washington DC then the only reason you
were doing that was to get a more
favorable jury speaking of the defense
the thing you're hearing already and I
think a lot of people at home will
wonder this is look lots of former
officials the former vice president
Pence Joe Biden have had documents where
they shouldn't have documents so what's
different in this Trump case well what's
different in this Trump case is the
Trump case didn't have to happen because
the Trump case could have been just like
vice president Pence and President Biden
if the government the National Archives
ask for their documents back because
they are the people that's the entity to
have of them well open up your home let
people come in which they both did which
they did and so they're right their
retention of documents was purely
negligent on the other hand Donald Trump
not only didn't let them in but he
returned things piecemeal and then he
absolutely decided to obstruct the
investigation according to the
government's allegations so what does it
mean to be charged under the Espionage
Act exactly well the Espionage Act of
course sounds like spying or it might
sound like leaking and perhaps for many
years that's how it was used it was also
used to quell dissent it's really very
simple it is the retention that is
holding on to documents that affect the
National Defense and not then giving
them back to the rightful owner the
United States of America and the
National Archives it's that simple so
Ricky were you surprised and I know
Donald Trump follows the beat of his own
drum but were you surprised that he
himself broke the news of the indictment
rather than the Department of Justice
yes I was very surprised that it came
from him I did not expect that to happen
when his lawyers have said don't do this
who knows what his lawyers will say and
does he listen to him and I was just
about to say and who knows if he listens
but for to come out before seven o'clock
at night after court was closed for the
day with nothing coming from the special
prosecutor was to my mind and experience
shocking
Bob what are you hearing from president
Trump from former president Trump's
Inner Circle about how Republicans are
responding to this news
Gail the Trump campaign is prepared for
both political and legal War this is
going to be a rocky period in American
politics because you have so many of the
Trump forces inside the party rallying
to his side even his Rivals like Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis said in a
statement last night the weaponization
of federal law enforcement represents a
mortal threat to a free society and on
Capitol Hill the speaker Kevin McCarthy
said this is a dark day for the United
States of America it is unconscionable
for a president to indict the leading
candidate opposing him a coercence as
the special counsel working within the
justice department not President Biden
doing that yet some Republicans publicly
are starting to question whether Trump
should carry on as the front runner in
this race as the potential nominee the
former Governor of Arkansas age of Asa
Hutchinson who's running for the
nomination as well said quote this
reaffirms the need for Donald Trump to
respect the office and end his campaign
behind the scenes in the Trump campaign
there's a alarm about what former white
house chief of staff Mark Meadows might
be doing in terms of possible
cooperation with the special counsel he
had such an inside view about what Trump
was doing in those final days when some
of those documents came back to Florida
Bob Ricky said she was surprised from a
legal perspective that Donald Trump
announced this indictment on true social
I imagine politically it's a different
set of of analysis uh he gets the
fundraise off this he gets the campaign
on it do you think it could help him in
any way
there is a belief that after the FBI
searched Mar-A-Lago last year that it
did help Trump politically it gave him a
boost but right now there's so much
uncertainty on the legal front and on
the political front there is a sense in
Trump's world that the Republican voter
out there whether it's in Iowa New
Hampshire or elsewhere could rally to
Trump's side but so many people in
Trump's Inner Circle have been saying to
him for months sir you're not going to
get indicted this is probably not going
anywhere it's not much of a case now a
former president faces a Federal
indictment it's serious it's real and no
one really knows how this is going to
play out because the indictment itself
has not been unsealed as it will be
early next week we don't even still know
the facts yeah there could be some
surprises in that indictment it's
important to keep that in mind and and
the reason there could be some surprises
is so many people have testified from
the janitorial staff at Mar-A-Lago to
his aides all of these people have been
pulled before a grand jury and ask
question after question what did Trump
do
with the things to keep in mind about
what we don't know yet is the question
of false statements and conspiracy to
obstruct justice so did he tell his
lawyers to do false things did his
lawyers know that did he tell people for
whom who worked for him to do false
things and remember this the worst
evidence against Donald Trump is once
again from Donald Trump he says he
retained these documents and by the way
they don't have to be classified so the
fact that he wants to say Declassified
them is irrelevant uh Ricky cleeman
always grateful for your analysis Bob
Costa for your reporting as always I
know you're still on this beat we'll be
hearing from you throughout the day in
the weeks ahead thank you very much